um
yes maybe you can see now yes anushka
i hope your voice should not echo now
i am sorry if it is still doing that
oh it's perfectly fine
let's wait for others to join as well
and then we'll start in 10 minutes
hi gerald how are you
and anushka and gerald i believe you
both were able to
uh get the access to the genomics in the
virtual lab video which i shared with
you the recording
yes ma'am i got the access i have been
able to view it
okay did you go through the session now
or not yet
i'm not the whole session but i had done
50
of it so far okay that means you have
finished one hour of the video and what
about you general even you are there
from the genomics in the virtual lab
program so i
wanted to ask did you go through the
session yet or not
okay you started
okay that's good and uh
whatever doubts you have please spend
them down we'll have a proper qna
session you can take your doubts there
and then we'll go ahead with your
process further
right is that clear
and uh just bookmark the page the
program page which i shared with you
both
so that you can uh have the access to
the
updates and the schedule as well hi
saran how are you
[Music]
hello good morning i'm fine how are you
doing how's everyone doing
good morning we are doing great great
saran you're from which university and
what are you pursuing right now
we see you have joined our session for
the first time i've never seen you
before
thank you for joining we would be
starting in a while let's wait for
others to join as well
hi charles how are you
so while we begin with this session it
would be good to know about you all
so i thought why not ask about your
research background
and also your research interests
hi charles you're from which university
and what are you pursuing
hi saran it's good to have you with us
here today from your you're from anna
university and what are you pursuing
are you a master student
if yes then in which field
hi anjali
okay so you are pursuing ptech and
pharmaceutical technology that's good
and which here are you right now
hi chinmay it's good to have you with us
here today
how are you doing
good evening dr sudha how are you
good to know that chimney we are waiting
for others to join as well and then we
may begin
hi anjali good evening
hi fernando
and you're from which field fernando
what are you pursuing currently
hi siren yes we will take you through
the topic of this session for sure
today is the first session for
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and we would be discussing about uh the
role of bioinformatics or precision
medicine and translational oncology
and we also discussed what we are going
to discuss in the further sessions
thank you
[Music]
fernando i was asking you're from
flitchfield
are you from bioinformatics only or
biotechnology
let's wait for two more minutes i see
more participants joining i
don't want them to miss out on anything
so we will begin
uh dot 8 30 pm ist thank you
okay so you are a computational
biologist good to have you with
us here today fernando
thank you for joining everyone
so while we start with the session i
request you all to please
uh keep your microphones on mute
now talking about today's session
precision medicine
is changing the way we understand
diagnose
and treat major life-threatening
diseases
and this transformation is driven by
high throughput molecular data
that is being collected from patients
animal models and
large-scale cell line experiments and in
this program bioinformatics or precision
medicine
we would explore how the various omics
data types generated in these studies
can be analyzed and integrated to study
the basic biology associated with the
viruses
and their hosts cancer onset and the
development
and outcomes as well my name is sunalika
ray
and i'm the omixlogic community manager
and i'm responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are
part of a bioinformatics community
managed by
pine biotech so before we start with
today's session i would want to
introduce us
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use accessible tools
and our mission is to make
bioinformatics more accessible
our mixed logic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omics logic is an international program
that is currently running in five
different regions
with over 10 000 users around the world
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local
and research coordinators that are
helping refine local program logistics
and leverage our online training
resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
this online program includes weekly
sessions with an
instructor online tracking and review of
student progress
access to all the resources and
materials online
for self-paced learning access to expert
guidance and problem solving
educational and research pipelines and
domain data analysis
on our big data server let me introduce
you to the program
mentors we have dr harpreet with us
she has an expertise in the application
of statistical machine learning
techniques
on biomedical data and the development
of prediction tools and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics
and data science course development dr
mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
and over the past several years he has
been developing collaborations with
universities
as a mentor and project lead for omics
logic training and research fellowship
and dr chipoliano chevas he is a
post-doctoral fellow at university of
chicago
he is skilled in bioinformatics and is
an expert in glioblastoma
now i would want to invite elia prosky
ceo pine biotech to discuss further
about the session over to eugenia
thank you very much and great to have
all of you here
today so today we'll
talk about our first session for
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and i want to begin with a brief
introduction to
what precision medicine is so maybe i
can ask that question to all of you
again thank you for joining i would like
to
ask all of you i'm sure that many of you
have the background and the expertise
and the interest in precision medicine
how would you define precision medicine
so if you could
use the chat to type in your answers i
would love to know what you think
so what is the definition of precision
medicine
hello hello yes hello
yeah a medicine which
cure the patient with minimal side
effects
okay excellent thank you uh
praveen anushka mentioned that this is a
method of disease treatment
as saran is mentioning that personalized
medicine based on pharmacogenomics
excellent enzyme asp
is saying that this is the use of tools
and approaches
in a more personalized way
all right excellent so great answers
everyone
and i think that we can turn to
a formal definition of what is
personalized medicine and what is
precision medicine because there's
actually a distinction between the two
okay excellent someone else is adding
here chiang mai is saying medicines
engineered to specific genotypes as to
enhance
efficacy gerald
medical solutions specific to the
genetic characteristics of an individual
all right vinay is saying customized
drug to each individual
so excellent answers let me read out the
formal definition
so precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment
and prevention that takes into account
individual variable
gene environment and lifestyle
for each person this approach will allow
doctors and researchers to predict
more accurately which treatment and
prevention strategies for a particular
disease
will work in which groups of people it
is
in contrast to a one-size-fit-all
approach
in which disease treatment and
prevention strategies are developed for
the average person
with less consideration for the
differences between individuals
so as you can see the personalized and
the
precision part of it are actually
intertwined and what's important is that
after decades of research
we now know that the detailed genetic
and other molecular information about a
patient's condition
can be and should be used to deploy
effective patient specific remedies
unfortunately the overall statement
that we are describing here is very
much a broad statement that lacks
certain details and those details
is what we want to focus on in this
program
but this is a good point for us to start
this discussion because
ultimately we mentioned the genotyping
so we
mentioned genes and specific genomic
information
we mentioned lifestyle and other types
of
variable factors that can affect the
treatment efficacy or outcome
and can also help us detect disease
early so we'll talk about these aspects
as well
and importantly what combines
all of these factors is that these
factors come from data
so today this data is superficial
based on symptoms that are categorized
with
clinical broad terms and we are moving
towards a more precise division of these
terms using
molecular phenotypes and molecular data
so
before we continue speaking about
precision medicine
briefly about myself and about our
company
we are a technology transfer company the
company originated at the university of
haifa in israel
and the company co-founders dr alfred
tauber and dr lena brodsky
combined the vision for precision
medicine and
the significant role that bioinformatics
plays
in precision medicine where the need to
integrate multi-omics data
is a very important part and
a cutting edge of research that is of
interest to many different clintons
as well as researchers around the world
but this
research effort has been taken into a
broader
to the broader audience by our team our
team includes
people that work on curriculum design
that help
design delivery methods to make this
content available online it also
includes programmers and
bioinformaticians that are skilled
in analysis of various types of data and
overall
our mission is to make data science
available for a broader audience
so the overall theme of the omixlogic
programs
is that we are focused on biology as a
data science
developing applications of high
throughput data analysis
to allow participants of all backgrounds
to utilize them and solve the need for
data literacy
in application to biomedical challenges
and so here you can see some areas
including
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience as well as
agriculture so to address this challenge
we actually have designed kind of the
three pillars of what our programs are
all about
so the goal of onyx logic is to provide
training
in bioinformatics guided by mentors in
pure example we
want to grow a community that shares a
passion for data-driven research in an
appreciation for
citizen science and we want to help
students clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in the lives of data science
and so we have been working on enabling
research
using these three things big data
analysis tools that are easy to use and
train people to use them effectively
provide mentorship by building a network
of mentors that are available
for answering your questions and guiding
your research
and then providing training and so this
program is one of the examples of
a training program that is designed to
provide you with very specific learning
outcomes and briefly i will mention also
how we will achieve that
for those of you that are joining this
program so one of the outcomes that is
very important in this
precision medicine topic is the basic
understanding of scientific literature
that describes analysis of omics data
through the lens of precision medicine
we will go through
project examples and literature that
will help you understand this topic
not from me but from experts that have
spent years researching these topics
and together we will learn how they have
applied
bioinformatics methods effectively to
extract meaningful
and translational ideas that are
applicable
in the clinical sense we will also focus
on
basic processing steps for next
generation sequencing data analysis with
consistent accuracy so independently you
can conduct such analysis
we will perform exploratory analysis and
generate a hypothesis from data or
data-driven research we'll focus on that
and you will be able to think about the
different categories and
factors in your data to design contrasts
for statistical tests
and prepare data for machine learning
you will also be able to annotate
found signal using biological databases
and references
identify appropriate data sets for
answering a biological question
plan your bioinformatics analysis from
start to finish independently
and present a project proposal including
the rationale
the methods scientific background and
anticipated results so these are really
the objectives for this program in the
context of
precision medicine or how does
bioinformatics
play a role in precision medicine
and to help us with all of this we have
this network
of mentors that will be accessible
throughout the summer
i will briefly we will briefly introduce
each one of them throughout the next
several programs that we have and the
summer training
programs are designed to actually lead
to a research project and for those of
you that are considering this path we
have
multiple programs available that include
precision medicine
source code 2 data analysis we have
programs on data science
focused on technical skills like coding
and machine learning
and we also have a research fellowship
program and the research fellowship
program
is a special opportunity that provides
you with
hands-on support and a research
focused group of people that can plan
and actually execute the analysis that
they're planning and develop
a research project in a short time now
for all of you that are
already a part of the research
fellowship or planning to find
a research fellowship that fits your
needs we welcome you to first join a
training program
like this one and then in the future as
you might be interested to work
more on a research project you can join
the research fellowship
for those that are working already on
project or and would like to join
a research symposium in august august
21st to 22nd we will have
a specially designed omics research
symposium that is organized with our
partners
at the louisiana biomedical research
network georgetown university
university of haifa and many others that
will provide you with an opportunity to
highlight your achievement through a
poster session and presentation of your
project
prizes and also to learn about
cutting-edge research and applications
of bioinformatics
undergraduate masters and phd programs
in bioinformatics including for
international students we will offer
also a glimpse of what the recruiters
and industry
are looking for in those that are
willing to apply
for a position how do you get into an
internship or how do you
identify job opportunities if you have
been trained in bioinformatics
and also we will discuss some effective
resources for training in education and
bioinformatics and data science
and obviously there will be prizes for
the best high school college and citizen
science
research project so we're excited and
we're looking forward towards this and
all of you that are
joining this session if you're a part of
our training programs or not
you are welcome to join and we will be
sending out information on this
soon so now let me turn
to bioinformatics for precision medicine
so this is our first session and in
today's session we will talk about
translational bioinformatics approaches
that lead to
effective outcomes and help address the
gaps
in precision medicine and let's start by
talking a little bit about the future of
medicine so what is the future of
medicine and where
are we to actually facilitate some
progress in this so i think that it is
obvious that to make these
better decisions about patients and
treatments and outcomes
there has to be aggregation of data
and there has to be an integration
between
lab data research data and data coming
from the patients
and all of this data has to be presented
to experts that understand the data in
such a way that they can discuss
the results of analysis in a meaningful
way and they can
translate this information to practical
decisions that they have to make
leading to an effective identification
of areas
of research that then could be addressed
by pharmaceutical companies
biotechnology companies and others that
are involved
in addressing the unmet needs and so
what we see this is as a combination of
personal and precise and there has to be
a number of components that come
together to make that possible
so beyond the general statements like we
have
discussed up until now let's talk about
how does this actually play out
in different examples so most people
would agree
that we can separate divide the diseases
into two kinds
infectious diseases and non-infectious
diseases so infectious diseases
are spread directly or indirectly from
one person to another
caused by pathogenic microorganisms such
as bacteria viruses parasites or fungi
and non-infectious diseases are not
caused by a pathogen and cannot be
shared from one person to another
they're caused by environments
nutritional deficiencies
lifestyle choices and genetic
inheritance
and so to study these diseases we can
leverage
data that is widely available
and what i wanted to do today is take a
look at some of these examples
to kind of identify what types of data
and what types of analysis
is appropriate for each type of data so
that we have a sense of what might be
the source of
information and the application of the
information that we derive
from such data so omix data in
infectious disease research can include
viral genomics and evolution and we all
know that this is a very
relevant topic today as we are in the
middle of a pandemic
and actually not just this pandemic but
we live
in an era of series of epidemics
starting from stars one
flew as you remember bird flu ebola
virus outbreaks
rhinovirus is now again reappearing so
we
live in an era of epidemics and
pandemics and
understanding the pathogens that cause
this in a precise way
is a component of precision medicine
or precision public health we also
understand now
different drivers of infection and
responses and those include our micro
environment
including the microbiome and immune
responses
and markers of the immune responses that
we can detect in patients
and ultimately when we speak about
infectious diseases
in a lot of ways we are talking about
again extracting
meaningful signal from the data so that
it can be made available to decision
makers that can
look at the data in an intuitive way so
they have to be
presented with that data in an intuitive
way but also they have to be trained
to be able to ask questions research
questions
based on the data that they see and lead
to
important research topics that can be
addressed effectively
in the lab in the research world and by
translational industry which means
pharmaceutical and biotechnology
industry as well as the clinicians
that can actually take some finding in
the
in that research realm and translate it
to practice
so the other topic that we mentioned are
non-infectious diseases and
non-infectious disease is a good example
for us to start with
where molecular information and
sequencing information plays a huge role
is cancer and as we all know cancer
is a growing concern we're much more
informed about cancer and what's obvious
today about cancer is that
there's a huge difference between types
of cancer
between the people that are affected
with different types of cancer
and the drivers of cancer
in the whole population around the world
and one of the clear signs is that
we know now that the cancer is
associated with aging
a lot of cancers are affecting older
people and so
as they become more risk
we need to understand how do we prevent
and how do we treat this cancer more
effectively
and one of the things that is very
important in this is the ability to
identify cancer onset and stratify
patients according to risk according to
outcomes and make sure that we
incorporate this information in the
treatment plan
and one of those is to identify markers
of cancer risk
so before we go on i have a few
questions
based on what we just discussed today so
what do you think
are some examples of omics data
that can help us study these conditions
including infectious diseases and cancer
what is an example of omics data
that is used in such research so if you
think about
different types of omics data maybe
you're familiar with different types of
omics data
you can write it out in the chat or if
you would like to unmute yourself and
say it
that is also fine so what is an example
of onyx data
okay so saran is mentioning metabolomics
dr sudha transcriptomics anushka jane is
also
saying transcriptomics okay excellent
ngs ngs can be used to
generate multiple types of omix data
okay dr saying genomics
metabolomics okay gwas is a method of
analysis that's good
metabolomics okay anyone else
what other so we mentioned
transcriptomics and metabolomics and
genomics three
any other types of omics data just
based on what we discussed already
epigenomics
okay so that's four what else
proteomics five lipidomic 6
metagenomics okay excellent
excellent i i think we we covered a lot
of epigenomics excellent
okay what kind of information can we
learn from
transcriptomic data okay so let's take
one of these
what kind of information can we learn
from transcriptomic data so there's
okay excellent gene expression okay so
what
gene expression is the information that
we extract from transcriptomic data
excellent what are some of the
challenges
with analysis of omics data
okay integration so fernanda fernando is
saying integration
zara is saying snips so snips i i'm
assuming you're referring to
what kind of information that is true we
can extract
the dominant snips from transcriptomic
data but more likely you're speaking
about genomic
data but what are some challenges with
analysis of omix data so fernando
already mentioned
integration that's an excellent
challenge right how do we
take these different types of sequences
and we extract
genomic data transcriptomic data and all
kinds of other data and
integrate them to understand what's
really going on okay what
what else what else do you think are
some of the challenges
and danilo is also mentioning isoforms
long non-coding rnas micrornas okay
excellent danielle thank you
so what are some of the challenges with
analysis of bombings data
all right thank you fernando saying
computational requirements right this is
big data now that we have thousands of
patients and each patient
is generating some genomic
transcriptomic metagenomic data
now we run into a problem of
computational resources
okay what additional challenges are
there
for okay data management exactly i've
analyzed this
i've analyzed that i have some tables
where did they come from how did i
generate them right
all of the data management questions
come to mind
okay great thank you everyone for your
questions last challenge
okay this is not for today
advances in next generation sequencing
so we talked about
omix data and a lot of the omix data is
coming from a very specific type of a
technology so
once it was discovered that the dna
encodes for genes that are then
transcribed into rna that are then
translated into protein
we now know that next generation
sequencing represents
an excellent opportunity to study these
molecular mechanisms of regulation
that lead to specific phenotypes
and ultimately we even mentioned here
proteomics lipidonics
metabolomics all of these are functional
enzymes and molecules
and proteins that define the phenotype
but
whatever is encoded in the dna and the
way that it is
translated into proteins and all of
these elements
that is the machinery that we can study
to
understand what is really going on and
the unique part
about next generation sequencing is that
the cost
of next generation sequencing has been
dropping very steadily over time so
if you think back to 2001
we started from a hundred million
dollars for the full genome to sequence
the full genome and
16 years later in 2017 for the first
time
the price of the genome the whole genome
sequence was
just around 1 000 and so because of that
not only is this data informative it can
give us
insights into what's going on but it is
also accessible
and affordable and it is approaching
that threshold
that makes it comparable to some of the
other tests that are being done
in the clinic already and we've been
using them for a long time
and so to really understand that we can
look at the history of genomic data
which started in the 1950s when the
double helix structure was understood
and then very rapidly if you think up
until 2018
we've already had thousands of genomes
that have been sequenced for hundreds of
thousands of patients around
the world and so as you can see the
price
the reduction in price led to an
explosion
of omics data that is now available
in research for companies and
biotechnology
and pharmaceutical industry as well as
in the clinic
and so to talk a little bit about the
different types of omics data we can
mention that
there are many different types of omics
data that we can extract
based on sequencing and to understand
the relationship between
genotype or what is found in the
sequence and the phenotype
the first one is phenomics we know that
cells
function and look very differently
tissues they form different
tissues if you take a look at the
morphology of a cell
it can tell you that there's a huge
difference in the way that it functions
between let's say
liver and blood right i mean think about
it one is a solid tissue
and one is a liquid one performs
one function another one performs
another function so obviously
that dna that contains information on
how to make those cells
includes all kinds of recipes that we
can study
and understand what is the potential of
all of these genes
to perform different types of functions
but ultimately
because of the phenotype differences we
know that not all of these genes are
equally activated and so we have to go
beyond just what's
encoded in the dna and we have to look
at how
is that dna regulated and so this is a
growing
area of research since about 2009 2010
there has been a tremendous interest in
epigenomic
data because it reveals epigenetic
regulation
how do these genes become more
accessible how
do they change from one isoform
to another isoform and so that
regulation
is called epigenomics that data like
chronic immunoprecipitation like whole
genome bisulfite sequencing
and many others microrna etc can really
reveal that
mechanism of regulation and then finally
we have transcriptomic data
which allows us to understand what has
actually been transcribed from the
messenger rna
and how can we study the various
isoforms
and transcripts that are being present
in a sample
now ultimately what does this lead us to
this lead us
leads us to a change in the way a
clinician
can look at a condition so if you think
of this iceberg
as a condition a patient that comes in
and says
my head hurts or i have a lump and so
on top on the surface what we know is
that there's some clinical
data that might be available but beneath
the surface
there are these layers of onyx data
that can reveal the molecular properties
driving this top of the iceberg clinical
phenotype that the patients are
describing or that we can capture with
tests like blood tests and
imaging and and other types of
traditional
forms of generating clinical data now
what's underneath the tip of the iceberg
underneath the tip of the iceberg we
have the transcription
the translation and the result of that
translation
as the protein and so what we know now
is that
we can take a look at specific proteins
that are critical for us to identify
patients that will respond
to certain therapies like the her2
protein
that help us categorize specific
patients
into subgroups and understand a lot
better
why certain patients have different
responses to treatment or have different
prediction
or different anticipation of recovery
and remission so one of the examples for
these
is the evolution of breast cancer
classification so we know that
breast cancer is actually a complex
disease
includes many different tissues in the
breast
that are affected and they also have
different properties they grow at
different rates they have different
success at treatment
and so when we think about breast cancer
classification
we now can separate breast cancers into
multiple
subtypes of the actual disease based on
protein expression based on gene
expression based on different types of
risks found in the
genome and different types of mutations
that are found in the genome
and so one of the ways that we will use
this example is to really look for how
does the prognosis responds to treatment
stratification of patients drug
purposing diagnosis target discovery and
risk
prediction are all components of
precision medicine that we are all
anticipating and so
here's a glimpse of how we can study
cancer using these kinds of technologies
we can look at
understanding of risk early on so the
earlier
the better we can address the problem
that we are anticipating
we can also look at likelihood of
response to treatment
we can look at different types of drug
safety parameters
better and so we can optimize the
treatment prevention and prognosis
ultimately for patients and hopefully
make sure that this disease is bringing
lower mortality in a longer healthier
lifespan for patients
but at the core of this problem is the
integration of data
so at the core of this we need to
understand how
all of these pieces of data
bioinformatics chemo informatics
clinical data how do all of them tie
together to provide us with
a better sense of diagnostics and
therapeutics
and the problem is that this is really
creating a gap
and a gap in understanding as well as
a gap in industries that are trying to
address this gap and so the way that i
think that
this data gap is
disrupting industries and why
there's a growing need in people like
yourselves that are learning
bioinformatics and that are learning
translational bioinformatics
is because all of these industries which
are huge
industries have to adapt to this new uh
status which is
that everything is data driven and the
data is becoming more complex
and so as we think about this we really
should turn
to how does this information coming from
research
get translated to actual useful
information
that and how is its information being
used
and so i think what we will do in this
program is we will start thinking about
how
experiments that are performed in the
lab with tissue culture
and cell lines how can they inform
the understanding of cancer and
a systems biology that we can study in
patient-derived genograph models and
animal models
how do these insights can get translated
to actual practical applications that
are applicable to patients
in clinical trials where we can test
drug responses
and improve the outcomes as well as to
the clinic
and one of the primary ways that this is
being done
is actually not even in the practice
realm
but first of all it is in the realm of
design and the design has to do with
data driven uh instead of a biological
hypothesis based approach right so
today the information is top down
so someone that has studied this topic
a particular type of cancer particular
type of a condition
is thinking and learning from
experiments and accumulates this
knowledge
and then designs experiments based on
their understanding and that is
hypothesis based
we take a textbook approach we identify
some important critical portion and we
design an experiment to validate
on the flip side of that of that is the
big data approach and the big data
approach is really saying
i have all of these accessible data sets
i can sample them and
sequence them and understand what is
going on to
start asking the questions how do i
address a particular
variation that i have found or how does
this affect
patients that i know of and so that is
really what this program is going to be
all about
how do we change our thinking to a
data-driven approach
to the research data sets that are
available online
linking them to clinical information
that we can also find online
and that link helping us to think of a
big data approach
to different types of conditions and
diseases and patients
that could ultimately benefit from
better treatment
earlier prediction and better prognosis
of outcomes
now i want to explain exactly how
can you benefit the most from joining
the program
by identifying specific steps that you
need to take
from this session up until the next
session to
get access to everything that you will
need to
practice the technical and the hands-on
activities that we will do
and to learn all of the material and so
to talk about that
i want to ask uh sonalika
to again talk us walk us through
how we can get access to all of the
resources that are needed
thank you so much helia let me share my
screen
yes so first of all i would want you all
to
sign up on the portal learn dot omits
logic
i will be sharing the link with you all
if you
all have signed up then just let me walk
you through how to update your profile
and things ahead but if you have not
let's
give you two minutes to please sign up
this is the link
learn.amislogic.com i would want you all
to please sign up here
you can sign up either by creating your
mail id and a password for yourself or
also you can sign up via your social
but i would recommend you sign up
creating a password for yourself
and while others are signing up
i would want to take few of the things
those who have already signed up
please login to your profile and
i would want to know in the chat box if
you have signed up by either sending a
one or a yes so that i know who all have
completed their sign up
so um so if you could please go to the
main page and just show from the
beginning
once people get on the portal how do
they actually take the steps to
make sure that they're registered thank
you yes
thank you so you can sign up either by
your id
and create a password for yourself or
via social
and let me just show how you can do so
via social
thank you for letting me know that you
have signed up
and those who have not they can sign up
with me because that is what you would
be required to go further in the process
for the program
thank you everyone
and now as you all have signed up like i
see many yes
those who are signed up i would want you
to take
to go through the update uh to update
your profile
and while i'm guiding the ones who have
signed up to update their profile
others can sign up in the meanwhile yes
so those who have signed up i would want
them to update their profile
and also link in their social accounts
linking in the social accounts would
help us
feature you all with your progress on
our social sites
and also uh we have a lot many
recruiters so
uh seeing your progress we could
also take your profile ahead
and highlight them in front of the
recruiters that would be a great help to
you as well
and please ensure that as a part of the
program you are a part of the
bioinformatics for
precision medicine program you must see
a badge
of precision medicine here on your
profile this is for those who have
already registered and are a part of the
program
and please ensure that you have a
starter subscription
accessed with your account if yes and
please send a yes
anushka gerald i can see you have said
yes as well please check this and please
let me know
that uh please ensure you have a starter
batch and also you have the badge for
the
program and also update your profile
picture and link can be social once your
profile is updated and you
can see your activity uh on the
profile itself and also you would be
able to get these certificates once you
complete
the given number of assignments for the
program
and also to go ahead with the project so
we would also take you further
to complete your project and upload it
in the later part of the
session but this is where you can just
look at your activity and get the
certificates as well and also look at
the courses and the programs that you
all
have covered so if you all have
completed your sign up sahara says no
batches only start a subscription
okay zara i'll look into it and zahara
uh are you enrolled for the precision
medicine program
i'm sorry we have not received your
enrollment yet
so if you have then please mail me at
marketing at the rate buying dot bio so
that i cross check i should not be
missing out on any of the enrollments
i believe now everyone has completed
their sign up and if not then i'll share
the link again and you can do so
uh meanwhile or maybe later
now this is the program page with which
you have to
keep a check on and just share the
program page link
this is the program page by which you
have to register yourself
now if you hover over the program page
we have mentioned all the session
details in the page itself which has the
calendar
so you would be you would stay updated
with all the
dates of the session and also the
session details on which day what
session would be covered
and on the program page in the session
details itself you would have the zoom
link here and also the recording of the
session would be
published on the program page after each
session is over so let's say after this
session the first session
i would be uploading the recording of
the first session on the program page so
that you can go to the recording
if you miss out something and then take
your doubts right
and all those who have enrolled that
already a part of the program page so
please make it sure that by tomorrow you
can see the recording of the session
and uh those who have not yet completed
the registration process and would want
to proceed further with the registration
on the same program page they would get
the option of the levels figure
intermediate and
advanced now these levels we have
segregated on the basis of the
provisions provided you can just go
through all the provisions which would
be
provided as a part of the program for
these three different levels
and those who are a part of an
intermediate and advanced
level they would get to do a research
project
under our mentor and they can uh
further we would be guiding them further
for how their research project has to be
uh covered ahead and how they have to
uh like go on from finding a data set
and then working on it doing the
analysis and then finally
uh publishing their work so we'll take
them through everything
towards the middle end those who are a
part of intermediate and
advanced levels and as a part of the
program you would also get the access
to a lot of asynchronous course material
on the portal
and the courses to which the access
would be given as a part of the program
are mentioned here on the program
page and the certificate which would be
uh given for the program is
mentioned here as shown here as well and
this is what the format of the
certificate looks like
and as a part of the program uh you
would also get the access to the t
buyer info server on which different
sorts of pipelines would be carried out
and the
analysis would be done our mentors would
be taking you through
uh the pipelines as well and how you
have to
uh go ahead with each and every analysis
now those who have enrolled for them it
is
to know that your login credentials
for the learn portal and the server
would be the same that is you
you must be able to login with your same
id
and password as that of learn on the key
by info server
as well and if you face any of the
issues then do let us know
we'll have a look and this is the
detailed syllabus
because i know you all must be excited
to know about the
syllabus topics would be for each and
every session
so this is the detailed syllabus page
i'll share the link of the syllabus page
as well
and you can go through all of the
associated online resources which you
will get as a part of
each and every session too and to your
knowledge we are also there on linkedin
and facebook i would want you to be a
part of our linkedin and facebook page
so that you stay updated with all the
upcoming
uh other opportunities as well and also
stay
updated uh with who is doing the best
like i told you that we would be
featuring your profiles with the
performance
on our pages and uh we are there on
linkedin by the name of honest logic
i'll share the link again and on
facebook we are there by the name of
pine biotech
and uh i'll just take a second more we
are
at present live on youtube so if you
would want to
go back and look at some of the uh
things which india mentioned you can go
to the link and
watch the recording over to you thank
you
thank you very much so i um
i'm going to show once you are logged in
so again for those of you that have
completed your registration
when you go to the program link in
sonarika if you could again post the
program
page on the program page you will find
the information that is already
relevant to what we are doing today so
right here you will see
the zoom link for example for our next
session
you will find the zoom link here once we
approach july 8th
and after today's session is over and
after you are done with
today's session you can click on
complete session
by marking this session as complete you
will start getting
points towards your certificate so you
can now see that i have
one out of ten sessions complete and
as you go through these you will also
see for the completed ones that we have
already done instead of the zoom
after the session is over this will
become a video
now as soon as i mentioned here you have
the different resources
and down at the bottom we also have a
slack channel
so if you have joined you can go to ask
the question
and this should open up slack if you
already have an account
you should be able to open slack
directly just like i'm doing right now
and if you don't have an account on
slack it's a free account
and you get to join our community of all
of the participants
so here you can see that all of you that
have joined
you should be a part of this slack
channel now on the slack channel we will
post important information about
practical assignments if you have any
questions you can ask them there
we will be posting the recorded sessions
and all of the needed information
in a timely way will be updated right
here
so again this is just a way for you to
be connected to all of the different
resources
and also you will find here a way to
book a meeting with us
or ask questions and also see your
certificate but all of this
is around your personal profile so
really as
i mentioned try to complete this profile
as soon
as possible okay so let me now
go and talk a little bit about why
this program is going to be focused on
data and how we're going to address this
problem
so the three things that our program is
going to provide you with
are the tools the skills and the
ideas about how to apply these tools and
data sets to different types of
challenges
and ultimately we're going to provide
you with a number of examples
of how you can take cellular omics data
understand the challenge in the
integration
and then try to understand the
relationship between
clinical and phenotypic data with the
different levels of omics data
that we will describe in detail
including genomic data transcriptomic
data
metagenomic data and others and as you
can imagine the obvious challenge
with this is that you are going to be
faced with many different technical
challenges that are going to be
difficult for those of you that do not
come from an engineering background so
here i would like to ask you a question
about your background okay
so i know that we have participants with
different
degrees so you could be a high school
student or a bachelor student or
a master's student or maybe a phd
or faculty so if you could please post
in
the chat box right now what is your
level of education your current level of
education
high school bachelor's degree master's
degree
phd or if you are a faculty
okay excellent thank you phd
masters phd faculty masters in
biotechnology faculty
masters in computer science excellent
master's in biochemistry
master's in biochemistry
okay i'll just give it a couple more
minutes phd
masters in technology and bioinformatics
okay excellent
okay so one of the challenges
in bioinformatics is that there are a
lot of
methods algorithmic methods there are a
lot of different types of data
and there are also a lot of things that
are not well defined so their
data wrangling data visualization
different types of
approaches to scripting that require
everyone to be
aware of how to just deal with data
what's called data literacy
and i think on the flip side on the
engineering side
what is oftentimes not clear to people
coming
from an engineering background is how do
these methods
of computer software essentially
address the problems in biology and so
this program is really designed to
bring those two together to take the
biological terminology
and the computer science slash
engineering aspects of bioinformatics
and bring them
closer together and to do that
we want to make sure that everyone is
familiar
with some of the basic ideas
about biological background
as well as the basics of computational
and data science
skills that you need to have and to do
that
we have designed a number of courses
that you should start with
so let me share some of those with you
okay so if you go to the
courses tab
you will find here some important
coursework
that you can start with as you are
getting started with this program or any
other program that we have
for those of you coming from an
engineering background
we recommend a course called bytes and
molecules
it will introduce you to some of the
basic terminology
and give you a sense of what is a
mutation what is gene expression
how do we use this information to answer
biological questions
for those of you that are not familiar
with bioinformatics
we recommend to get started with this
course called introduction to
bioinformatics
and that will give you some perspective
on the applications of bioinformatics
in general like the introduction to big
data bioinformatics how do we start
thinking with this
driven instead of a hypothesis driven
research
how is bioinformatics used in healthcare
and
biomedical research and then also what
is translational bioinformatics so
if you have just registered recently or
you
are now registering
please make sure that you start with
these courses
okay so again you create a profile and
once you create a profile this is a free
course so anyone can take this
and once you have completed this course
again you can click always on your name
right here
and you can go to the course tab to see
your progress
with different courses so by next time
that we meet
please make sure that you have completed
introduction to bioinformatics
and bytes and molecules so these are
going to be important courses for you to
complete
so that we can all continue and move
forward
now the other side of things is that you
will need
access to our big data analysis platform
okay so let me briefly explain how it
works
and what we will do using a
short example okay please go to this
link
server.tbio.info
for those of you that registered today
you probably don't have your access
yet for those of you that have
registered previously
starting from yesterday you should be
able to use your
uh omixlogic login details your email
and your password
to be able to get in so please let me
know once you're logged in
you should be able to see your name
right here your email address right here
under your profile okay put number one
if you can log in or no so
number one or yes if you can log in
number two or no
if you cannot log in
okay so dr sudha again given that you
have created
an account on omixlogic not today
so if you just created your account
today you still don't have access
it takes up to 24 hours for your profile
to be created on the big data analysis
platform but for those of you that have
registered a while ago yesterday or
before that
you should already have your login okay
so anjali pravin dr
sudha i am assuming you just registered
today correct
yes so if you just registered today you
will not have access but
you can still follow along and then
tomorrow you can replicate the same
steps so your free account will come
with this information
so let me briefly introduce you to what
we can do
on this portal and to do that i will
take an example project
that we will go through in our
discussions
okay so gerald when did you
sign up okay
so gerald if you can try and
uh sonalika maybe you could help uh
gerald
uh he should have his account set up
already
if he doesn't maybe dr harpreet can help
him okay so once you're in
you will see that this is a big data
analysis
environment that you can use to
try out a number of different approaches
to analysis of big data
and instead of going into the main
section what we will do is we will
open it up as a drop down and we will
take
at this cell line project the first
project right here
so once you're inside you will see that
this is a
graph of different methods each box here
represents
an algorithm and this algorithm has a
logical
purpose that logical purpose is stated
in the box above
so when we take raw sequencing data we
would like to
clean this data we would then like to
map it on the genome
make sure that we are capturing the iso
forms and recording them in the gtf file
mapping this information on transcript
so we know transcript
abundance by quantifying expression
levels
and then performing differential gene
expression or even just preparing our
table of expression for downstream
analysis
and so to illustrate how you can go from
raw data
to structured data i will just
demonstrate a brief step-by-step process
where we start we clean up the data
with traumatic and pcr clean
we then can map onto the genome
isoform construction using cufflinks
add that information to the gtf file
using gtf processing
mapping on transcripts using bowtie2t
preparing an rsm gene expression table
that looks like this
and then we can actually click on end
to see the output files and so here you
will see a number
of different outputs so in a similar way
what we will do in this program is we
will go through genomic data
transcriptomic data metagenomic data and
introduce you to some of the common
tools and methods that you need to
understand
and place them in the right position in
the bioinformatics pipeline
to get meaningful results does anyone
have any questions about this before i
go on
okay the second thing that you will be
introduced to
are some data repositories
so we will not just take data sets that
we give you but we will actually
introduce you to repositories where you
can find data independently does anyone
here
have any sense of where to find data
about cancer omics data about cancer
i'll give you a hint one of the
repositories is right there on the
screen
all right excellent c bio portal tcga
excellent so what is tcga
what kind of data do we have on tcga
leena
okay cancer genome atlas so dr asunahan
okay what kind of data do we actually
have on tcga
okay the answer is we have patient data
so there are
a number of different tumors that
exactly
cancer genomic data cancer
transcriptomic data so it's multi-omics
data
that has been integrated so we can
easily search and find different types
of data but beyond that
there are also data sets on ncbi for
example
national center for biotechnology
information so we will also go through
some research papers
that describe applications of cancer
cell line
and patient derived xenograft models of
animal models
that we can use to find interesting
insights like
biomarkers that have a computational
component to them and allow us to
predict
outcomes for different types of
treatment response
so we will take a look at some of those
data sets in the tcga data sets
we will take a look at the association
between clinical information
and genomic information as well as other
other types of omics
and ultimately we will also take a look
at some infectious disease research
challenges where we can identify
important
information about infectious diseases
and the pathogens that cause them as
well as the immune responses so
as a result you will find important
information on how to perform standard
analysis
like phylogenetic analysis gene
expression
composition analysis of
alignment and variant calling insights
into structural biology
and how to integrate all of these data
sets so we will talk about those and
what i recommend to get started is to
start looking
at some of the important project
examples that we will be using
throughout this program okay where do
you find them
again you go to courses and you can
start looking through some of the
examples right here for example
tcga liver cancer project on precision
oncology
or covenanting origin and pathogenesis
of source cove2
so if you have an interest in cancer
type data
or in infectious diseases you can find
some project examples
okay so finally i want to mention again
that
all of this information is going to go
towards
your own individual progress so even
though this is a program it brings you
together as a group
the objective is for you to grow
personally and we hope that you will be
able to develop an independent project
so how do you go from learning about
these skills
and trying out different examples to
actually
developing an independent project as
sonic already mentioned
we have a system designed to help you
go from learning to then application
and that will be focused on the aspect
of developing
a bioinformatics project so we hope that
this program will help you start
conceive of a project and then start
thinking about how do you actually
conduct the analysis that you have
planned
so if you're a phd you're already
working in some kind of a
project where you have omics data you
want to integrate it this is not just
going to be learning about
bioinformatics this is going to be
let's do bioinformatics let's get this
done and let's apply these tools
to a data set of your own and for that
you
need to have the advanced account
and advanced registration for the
program or
you can participate in the research
fellowship program as
a additional level to your subscription
with this program
and then pursue your project
independently so
before we leave i want to leave you
with this slide where you will find
important courses that you can start
with
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and molecules
as well as some information about how to
get started
with bioinformatics in python and in r
and how to design a bioinformatics
research project so if you're coming
from a life science background
how do you actually think about
selecting a topic finding that data set
and then applying what you learn in this
program to design
an independent bioinformatics research
program and once you start making
progress
you will see that on this page you have
some simple steps
for you to get to a level where you can
conduct a
project independently with our support
and then publish it
on here as a featured project
and just to give you a sense of what
that looks like if you scroll all the
way to the bottom of this page
you will find here a couple of examples
glioblastoma
covid19 drug repurposing and lymphocytic
leukemia
will give you a good sense of what you
can come out with
as you develop these project ideas
during this program
so that's all we wanted to share in
terms of today's session
so malik i will pass it on back to you
if you have anything to add before we
close and if
anyone has any questions that i can
answer please put them in the chat
and we'll be happy to see you again next
time
thank you so much ilya and thank you so
much everyone so listen
uh for listening so patiently so today
we discussed about the role of
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and in the next sessions we would be
going through the practical aspects and
also we'll take you through the project
samples and go forward with carrying out
the analysis
and also we would be talking about next
generation sequencing and big data
analysis
and then we would go towards discussing
the applications for
infectious diseases that would be viral
and bacterial infections
and then also discuss about the omics
data the role of hormones data
in cancer research be it genomics
transcriptomics or epigenetics
and we would be waiting for you all
to interact with in the next sessions
thank you for joining today
and so yes so we have few questions
thank you easy for answering
also there was one question i think it
went and answered let me take that
and you can ask the questions if you
have
any sort of in the chat box right now we
can answer it them for you
so just about the software i want to
clarify
if you are going to participate in all
of the sessions
in future sessions you will require some
software like
integrative genome browser
um you will be able to browse
vcf files and see how we can identify
mutations that are present in some
samples so we will have some
of that software that is described in
the projects that we will discuss
and uh for those of you that are wanting
to participate in a project with an
intermediate enrollment you can
but the intermediate enrollment does not
give you enough time
so the training that will come first
will prepare you to design a project
proposal
but it will not give you enough time to
actually complete your project and so we
recommend having the advanced
subscription or if you already have an
intermediate enrollment
also consider joining the research
fellowship program
which will give you three to six months
to actually complete your project
yes thank you so much
and uh also i was getting the questions
from
lbrn participants so bioinformatics for
precision medicine
is not a program for the lbrn uh
it is not under the programs under lbrn
so if you would want to uh proceed your
application
for by information precision medicine
program i'll just
mail you all the details
and yes for those of you from lbrn that
want to participate in this program in
addition to other programs that
you're involved in we can definitely
take your
information and share it with the lbrn
leadership
to see if they are going to provide some
kind of scholarship for you
but we do need to have your details for
that and we need to know for sure that
you are interested
and i know the praveen did you want to
ask something i'm sorry i think you were
interrupted
okay okay no no
okay okay no problem
um nearby if you completed a
master's in biotechnology you want to
learn bank without any pay program
yes you don't have to pay you can learn
a lot about bioinformatics on your own
for free there are many resources online
we provide some of the free
resources like introduction to
bioinformatics so please do take the
course introduction to bioinformatics
no cost completely free just make a
profile nearby and start learning
okay excellent thank you everyone and
glad that all of you joined
and looking forward to seeing you again
next time
you so much everyone i'm just dropping
my mail id if you have any of the dolls
you
you can ask me it's marketing at the
refine dot
bio or you can also find me at mohit
anthony pine dot bio
or marketing at the root or massage.com
uh vinay yes i'll share the i've added
you
to uh to the slack channel already so
please check your
uh mail id you would get the email from
uh the invitation for the slack channel
thank you jason
thank you everyone for joining we are
looking forward